Alis Weidel jetzt die Fraktionschefin
der
[Applaus]
AFD sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Bundeskanzler sehr geehrte
Damen und
Herren keine zwei Jahre Ampel und
Deutschland steckt in der Dauerkrise und
steht am Rand der
Zahlungsunfähigkeit dieser
Verfassungsbruch ist beispiellos in der
Geschichte
Deutschlands die Bürger
haben in dieser Lage nicht auf ihre
Regierungserklärung gewartet herr Scholz
sondern auf ihre
Rücktrittserklärung zwei Drittel der
Deutschen wollen dass diese Ampel
endlich ein Ende nimmt dass diese
Regierung immer noch im Amt ist zeigt
ihre Missachtung für souverän den Bürger
sie haben genug von einem Kanzler der
sich mit angeblichen Gedächtnislücken
aus seiner Verstrickung in ein der
größten
steuerbetrugsskandale der Republik
herauswinden will Beweismittel
verschwinden sie haben genug von einem
ökonomischen Analphabeten als
Wirtschaftsminister der die Wirtschaft
zu Grunde richtet und die
bürgerüberheizungsdiktate
ignet sie haben genug von ein Ministerin
die 100000 € im Jahr für Styling ausgibt
aber von einem diplomatischen disaster
ins nächste stolpert sie haben genug das
ist wunderbar dass sie wieder aus der
FDP da rausbrüllen sie haben nämlich
auch genug von einem FDP Finanzminister
der verfassungswidrige Haushalte
verabschiedet um dieses grüne
Narrenschiff mitzufinanzieren und der
die Schuldenbremse abschaffen will und
sie haben genug von einer
Innenministerin die selbst das größte
Sicherheitsrisiko ist weil sie die
Grenzen und die Bürger nicht schützen
will diese Koalition regiert gegen die
Vernunft gegen die Wirklichkeit gegen
den Willen und das Wohl der Bürger und
sie regiert gegen unsere
Verfassung wir stecken in der tiefsten
Wirtschaftskrise seit es die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland gibt die
Deindustrialisierung ist im vollen Gange
ein insolventz Zunami nach dem anderen
rollt über unser
Land das ist ihr Werk das ist ihr Werk
ihres
planwirtschaftsministers und ihrer
hochsventionierten Energiewende und
Klimapolitik sie verteuern
Energie durch Staatseingriffe verteilen
dann subvenstion an Teile der Industrie
während sie den Mittelstand mit
horrenden Energiepreisen hängen lassen
und über CO2 Abgabe und
transportmauterhöhung zusätzlich die
Preise noch erhöhen diese
interventionsspirale führt direkt in die
Verarmung
Unternehmen Normalverdiener und Rentner
bluten für ihre
Transformation sie brechen selbst ihr
Versprechen die Steuer für die
Gastronomie nicht wieder anzuheben damit
geben sie dem gasgewerbe den Todesstoß
ihr Bürgergeld treibt die sozialkrise
auf die Spitze die fleißigen werden
bestraft kein Wunder dass in ganzen
Branchen wertvolle Arbeitskräfte aus der
Steuer und abgabenspirale in das
Bürgergeld flüchten bearbeitet ist der
Dumme wer arbeitet ist der dumme und
legt nicht mehr für sich und die Seinen
in den Rücken krummen sondern für
Abkassierer aus aller Welt
62% der Familien im bürgergeldbezug
haben keinen deutschen Pass ihr
Bürgergeld ist ein
Etikettenschwindel es ist ein
migrantengeld ein
einwanderungsmagnet die
migrationskrise bringt unser Land an den
Rand des
Zusammenbruchs fast eine halbe Million
sozialmigranten allein dieses Jahr
rechnet man die yl Erstanträge und den
Familiennachzug zusammen das kostet uns
nach den offiziellen Zahlen 50
Milliarden Euro jährlich sie bringen
diese Menschenmassen in Luxushotels
unter und Quartieren sie in Altenheime
ein während die Normalverdiener und
Rentner kaum noch über ihre Runden
kommen und trotzdem lassen sie die Tore
sperangelwald offen und glauben sie
können das Volk durch wirkungslosen
Aktionismus noch einmal ruhig stellen
die Bürger aber spüren am eigenen Leib
dass die unkontrollierte
Masseneinwanderung in eine umfassende
sicherheitskrise geführt hat viermal
mehr Deutsche als
Zuwanderer werden Opfer von tötungs
Gewalt und Rohheitsdelikten als
umgekehrt die Gewaltkriminalität
explodiert die Zahl der ausländischen
Straftäter auch für Frauen ist der
öffentliche Raum zum Risikogebiet
geworden dass sie lieber meiden mehr als
zwei brutale
gruppenvergewaltigung am Tag verzeichnet
die
Kriminalstatistik was haben sie da auf
unser Volk
losgelassen für den Verfall der inneren
Sicherheit tragen sie von der CDU und
CSU genauso die
Verantwortung und auf einmal emp Sie
sich über importierten islamischen
Judenhass als hätten sie eben erst
bemerkt dass es den gibt sie haben
hunderttausende junge Männer ins Land
geholt die in judenfeindlichen
gewaltbereiten Kulturen sozialisiert
sind sie lassen zu dass
fundamentalistische
Islamverbände einen Staat im Staate
bilden die Verantwortung für wachsenden
Antisemitismus haben sie mit Fake
Statistiken der einheimischen
Bevölkerung
zugeschrieben
Aktionismus ist heuchlerisch solange sie
weiter über den alltäglichen deutschen
feindlichen alltagsterror gegen die
einheimische Bevölkerung
schweigen die Krise ist längst eine
umfassende manifeste Vertrauenskrise
geworden ihre Politik delegitimiert die
demokratischen Institution in den Augen
der rlichen Bürger sie ist das
vernichtende Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes überhaupt gar
nicht gegeben sie wollen auf diesen
Verfassungsbruch gleich den nächsten
Folgen lassen aber sie haben gar kein
Milliardenloch das ist lächerlich es ist
absurd in Anbetracht eine
rekordgesamtsteuereinnahme von einer
Billion
Euro das muss man sich mal vorstellen
eine Billion Euro das heißt sie haben
nicht zu wenig sie haben
rekordgesamtsteuereinnahmen mit denen
sie gar nicht K wie alle
Sozialisten der Weg aus der Krise führt
über die Rückkehr zur Vernunft stoppen
Sie die Massenmigration indem sie die
Grenzen schließen und
einwanderungsmagneten wie Bürgergeld
Kindergrundsicherung passverramschung
und Aufenthalt für alle abschalten lösen
Sie die klimafond auf und beenden Sie
das Milliardengrab Energie und
mobilitätswende ist so einfach
verzichten Sie darauf Milli in alle Welt
zu verteilen für ideologische
Entwicklungshilfe Klimaschutz in Indien
und auch für die Ukraine reduzieren Sie
die Zahlung an die EU und setzen Sie
sich für eine freiheitliche Reform der
europäischen Staatengemeinschaft ein
dann bleibt auch Geld für die Lösung der
dringenden Probleme in unserem Land
Senkung der Steuern und Abgaben
Förderung von Familien sichere Renten
Sanierung des Gesundheitssystems
Wohnungsbau bessere Schulen Innenstädte
und Grenzen und eine funktionierende
Armee sie aber riskieren steuerkollaps
Chaos und den Staatsbankrott und darum
brauchen wir eine neue Regierung um aus
diesem krisensumpft herauszukommen darum
öffnen Sie den Weg für neue Wahlen und
erlösen Sie dieses Land von der
ampelregierung ich bedanke
mich